so there is a group of women accusing
marilyn manson
of sexual assault evan rachel wood who
is an actress i've actually never seen
her work
but she and i got into some kind of
twitter spat one time and
so that's that's the only way i became
aware of her but she is probably the
most prominent person
uh leading this charge other women are
doing it too though
we'll get into those accusations because
i i actually think
that no matter how sort of
cheapened this this debate has become
the the left does kind of have a point
here
i just want to zoom out for a second
marilyn manson
he took his stage name from marilyn
monroe and charles manson one of the
most famous killers in american history
marilyn manson the highest profile
satanist in america
he was friends with anton levay who was
the head of the church of satan
he described himself as a minister in
the church of satan
he was a devotee of alistair crowley
maybe the the other
most famous satanist of the last hundred
years he quotes crowley in his
autobiography says that
crowley's sort of central dictum is very
important to him which is
do what thou wilt shall be the whole of
the law
a lot of other references to crowley
turns out the satanist abuses people
not exactly a man bites dog
story but it is in our culture because
we we have
so lost our perspective on these things
that we would be shocked we say oh
there's there's nothing strange about
being a satanist no it's fine it's
actually good that's all the same
we can't discriminate you see this in
lawsuits often you'll have some
satanists
suing a church or suing rather a
courthouse
is they have the ten commandments we say
that the church of satan
and the actual church the christian
church they're sort of the same thing we
can't
we have to be neutral between those two
our founding fathers rolling over in our
in their graves on this
but let's get into the actual
accusations
viewer discretion if people are uh
younger right now listening to this
maybe just close their ears for about a
minute or two
evan rachel wood before she said that
she was abused by marilyn manson
testified before congress and said she
was abused by a sort of
former ex-boyfriend you know who
she's going to leave nameless here is
her description of the abuse
my experience with domestic violence was
this toxic mental physical and sexual
abuse which started slow but escalated
over time
including threats against my life severe
gaslighting and brainwashing
waking up to the man that claimed to
love me raping what he believed to be my
unconscious body
and the worst part sick rituals of
binding me up by my hands and feet
to be mentally and physically tortured
until my abuser felt i had proven my
love for them
in this moment while i was tied up and
being beaten and being told
unspeakable things i truly felt like i
could die not just because my abuser
said to me i could kill you right now
but because in that moment i felt like i
left my body and i was too afraid to run
he would find me i froze
and it was as if i could see myself from
the outside and for the first time in
months i felt something
utter shame and despair i had no idea
what to do to change my situation so i
went numb
and soon i couldn't feel anything i
wasn't alive my self-esteem and spirit
were broken
okay pretty ugly stuff jenna jameson who
is a former porn star
um who dated manson sort of at the
height of his fame
didn't describe anything like that but
she did say he he bit her
you know he was very into like biting
and sort of a bruising and painful way
and uh said that he had fantasies about
burning her alive so i guess it does
kind of jibe a little bit with what evan
rachel was describing
about the unnamed ex-boyfriend
there are two important parts of this
story
that show how modern liberal culture
exacerbates all of this stuff
right these left-wing
women are not complaining other than aoc
taking a cheap political shot that has
nothing to do with the actual issue
these women are not complaining
generally speaking about conservative
men marilyn manson is not exactly a you
know a conservative republican or
something
they're complaining about people who buy
into this leftist idea the metoo
movement is focusing on all these
leftist dudes from the sort of
least serious accusations you think of
like aziz ansari
where they're basically describing this
like very grass bad date
or all the way up to harvey weinstein
these guys are liberal democrats right
so it's
whatever the issue is if it has a
political dimension the political
dimension is going to be on the left
in the case of jenna jameson's
descriptions here and in the case at
least in part of
evan rachel wood the sick behavior
that they're describing was consensual
right when evan rachel wood's talking
about and we had this ritual that we
would do
so we'd do it multiple times right if
it's a ritual where he'd tie me up and
beat me and
say all these horrible terrible things
to me
and i didn't it was ruining my
self-esteem but that was obviously
consensual and there are even many
people on the right now
certainly the left says this but even
many people on the right who say look if
it's consensual it's
totally cool that is the highest
political good is
consent look if as long as you two
consent to it you can do whatever you
want there's nothing about
but actual conservatives conservatives
who understand that there's a
transcendent moral order
realize no things can be done
consensually that are still extremely
wrong
on paper what not the first part about
waking up but
all the the rituals whatever rachel what
is describing was consensual and it was
still
wrong and it was wrong for her to
consent to it i suppose i mean it wrong
just because of how it obviously hurt
her and tore her up inside
but it was wrong for the dude even if he
got consent
to do it it just remains wrong consent
is not enough
there is a higher good than consent the
second aspect of this though
that that sort of overturns this leftist
prevailing notion about sex is
this shows that sex is not a casual
thing
the culture that we're all living in the
ubiquitous culture especially on college
campuses but especially just among young
single people is that sex is kind of
casual it's basically like a handshake
well now handshakes are illegal
because of covid but so i guess it's
even more casual than a handshake
and it's totally fine you go and you
just hook up with whoever you want and
then
next day is no big deal and nobody gets
hurt because it's consensual right it
does tie into that issue
and that's just obviously not true and
here's how i'll show you it's not true
the punishments for sexual assault are
more severe than punishments for simple
assault
right if i if i go up to some dude on
the street or we're in a bar or
something
and we're talking and we're getting
angry and i punch that guy in the face
i'll get in trouble you know that
involves some punishments
but the punishments are not as severe as
rape
why because sex is not just a casual
thing
if it were simple assault and sexual
assault would be indistinguishable
but sex is a very serious thing it's
very significant
and it's not even purely a physical
phenomenon
it has a spiritual component too and i
know that liberals and the modern left
in particular
and even some segments of the right who
are a little more licentious
don't want to admit any of that because
i don't know because some of this stuff
is fun you know
when it's happening and when everyone's
doing it but nevertheless that is true
there are these scare tactics that go
around like college campuses and they've
become very popular over the last
30 40 years this the statistics you'll
hear is that one in four women or one in
five women
on college campuses will be sexually
assaulted while they're there they'll be
raped while they're on campus
that is obviously not true if that were
true no parent would ever send
his kid or her kid to college
right you wouldn't could you if someone
said hey we've we uh
we've got a great place where your
daughter can
read aristotle they're probably not
anymore they'll probably read ibram
candy or something now
but we got a great place where your
daughter can go she reads some books
she'll get a credential
one in four chance though that she'll be
the victim of rape
would anybody if anybody actually
believe that would they say oh
okay sign me where do i sign up oh and i
get to pay a quarter million dollars for
the privilege great
terrific no of course nobody believes
that but those numbers
come from uh these sort of activist
surveys
i detail some of this actually in my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds which you can
pre-order now it's not coming out for a
few months though
one of the tricks to some of these
surveys is that they'll ask women
describe these experiences
describe if you believe you're a victim
of rape or sexual assault
and then they'll they will after the
fact
define many women who do not think that
they're victims of rape
as victims of rape and the reason that
they'll do this
or rather the theory that they're
pushing as they do this
is this idea of false consciousness
which is a marxist idea
that became very prominent in the 1970s
with second wave feminism it's become
very prominent with the rise of things
like critical race theory which people
have been talking about
over the past few months that you you
are not aware
of your own oppression so you need to
have your consciousness raised
this was a ritual of the new york
radical women's groups
and when your consciousness is raised
you'll realize
how oppressed you are there's actually a
funny essay about this
where a woman describes how she she went
to a new york radical women's
consciousness raising party she says you
know when i showed up
i was totally happy i was just a regular
housewife i was totally happy
only by the end did i realize how
oppressed i am
and thank goodness for that women's
group you think well
did you really get your money's worth
there it doesn't seem like a great way
to spend
time so the statistics are crazy no
nobody really believes that harvard yard
is more dangerous to women than downtown
baghdad right
nobody seriously believes that but it's
about redefining all of those terms
well as they've done so they've also
redefined
what would be by any normal standard
abusive sex as
perfectly fine and dandy and kind of fun
and
kinky and consensual but the testimony
we're
seeing just just with regarding or just
with regard to the marilyn manson case
the testimony we're seeing is
no that can still be abusive as well and
i think it's just
we've got to shake this is part and
parcel of something we've been talking
about for a couple weeks now
we've got to stop pretending that
consent is the be-all and end-all
there is something higher it's not even
just
it ties in with the idea that it's not
just that we protect freedom of speech
that's great
you need something to say you need to
believe certain things
and exclude other things it's not just
about consent you have to
it depends what you're consenting to the
the acts themselves really matter
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got the
absolute top content
out there
you